it's been one of the longest-running
mysteries throughout this pandemic was
all of the crucial data that was
announced at those press conferences for
instance there with Matt Hancock
actually accurate will now finally we
can give you some of the answer and I
want to start by casting your mind back
to the 21st of May it was one of those
press conferences where the health
surgery was actually giving it an
alongside it
there was this table of data so deaths
number of tests and so on and the key
thing I want you to focus on here is
this the number of people tested over
two million according to this data that
was released at the time was that
actually accurate well let's have a look
what we've now learned you can see this
was what was said at the time so those
daily updates from the government we
know already the numbers for tests at
number of people tested in Northern
Ireland Wales and Scotland and now for
the first time following the sky news
investigation into data earlier on this
week the government has released data
for England and here's what it shows you
just look it's short of that total that
we were told about earlier on in May in
fact if I just kind of put those all
together that gap accounts for about
200,000 people in other words it was
overstated that total was overstated by
about 200,000 so it shouldn't have been
two million that the health secretary
and indeed the government we're talking
about around that time it should have
been about 1.8 million it's an enormous
revision due to all sorts of double
counting and we have just had the data
through it's been a long-running mystery
as I say because rather than just
updating that data the government over
the course of the next few weeks and
indeed months from the 23rd of May
onwards just said that takes a look was
unavailable now we finally know it was
simply unreliable and we know the
picture for sure or indeed for sure as
far as the latest data is concerned
that's what health and social care says
throughout the pandemic we've been
completely transparent about the data we
collect and publish and are always
looking to improve our statistics
including on testing